jedes mal wenn ich so schlag sein lese
dann triggert mich das sehr fremde
ostdeutschland ist irgendwie ein
sonderfall warum sind die ostdeutschen
so krawallig wie rechts ist der osten
der osten bleibt anders und das zeug zum
klassiker hat ja der spiegel titel
so ist der ossi genau der ostdeutsche
das seltsame tierchen das ist es doch
was bei all diesen überschriften immer
irgendwie mitschwingt die sind irgendwie
anders irgendwie komisch diese
ostdeutschen ich bin selbst im osten
geboren und deshalb geht mir das auch
wahnsinnig auf den keks und noch mehr
nervt mich dass die politik seit 30
jahren keinen umgang mit uns den
ostdeutschen findet wenn ich
bundeskanzlerin dann wird ostdeutschland
ganz oben auf der tagesordnung der
deutschen politik stehen wo habt ihr das
gehört nach 30 jahren macht die spd den
osten zur chefsache ja und auch armin
laschet hat gerade sein herz für den
osten neu entdeckt auch als
kanzlerkandidat interessiert mich ganz
besonders der osten und die probleme die
die menschen in diesem teil deutschlands
haben interessiert mich auch also öffnen
wir stilecht eine tüte knusperflocken
und gucken wir uns dem problem falls mal
zusammenhang aber warum ist der politik
denn eigentlich gerade der osten so
wichtig es ist ja bundestagswahl könnte
es sein dass die wahl im osten
entschieden worden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin christiane hübscher ich bin
korrespondentin im zdf hauptstadtstudio
und ein alter wahlkampfspruch der geht
ja so man kann die wahl in
ostdeutschland vielleicht nicht gewinnen
aber man kann sie doch verlieren das hat
mir schon gesehen helmut kohl und
gerhard schröder und das jetzt schon mal
gezeigt
das war michael kellner das ist der
wahlkampfleiter der grünen und das sagt
er zwar so nicht im interview aber
natürlich haben die grünen im osten
gerade ein problem
genau wie übrigens die linke früher mal
die ost partei aber gerade in sachsen
anhalt wieder ordentlich abgeschmiert
gericht dass die linke es im osten hat
auch schwierig hat tatsächlich alte
wahlergebnissen zu erreichen
der osten es natürlich noch ein ganz
besonderes pflaster heißes pflaster
ostdeutschland nur 15 prozent aller
wahlberechtigten leben hier aber die
können eben am ende entscheidend sein
hier sind meine top 3 der gründe warum
es geht schon mal damit los dass alle
drei kanzlerkandidaten eine west
biografie haben und zwei von ihnen haben
das gleiche problem
sie kommen nicht besonders gut an im
osten hier schaut man aus politbarometer
armin laschet und annalena baerbock
werden in westen eher für
kanzlertauglich gehalten als im osten
nur oder falls bekommt im osten ein
bisschen mehr zustimmung und das obwohl
berger ja schon lange in brandenburg
lebt hier sogar um ein direktmandat mit
scholz konkurriert und trotzdem muss sie
sich fragen lassen kann wie osten die
ard wiederum fährt im osten regelmäßig
erfolge von über 20 prozent ein der
ostbeauftragte der bundesregierung marco
wanderwitz heißt der geboren in sachsen
von der cdu er hat ja kürzlich gesagt in
einem interview viele ostdeutsche seien
eben immer noch diktatur sozialisiert
uhu und würden deshalb so gerne afd
wählen was dann gefolgt ist habt ihr
vielleicht mitbekommen waren ein
ordentlicher shitstorm sogar die
kanzlerin hat mehrfach angerufen sagt
mir wanderwitz ja aber was nicht schon
beeindruckt hat er stehen geblieben in
diesem sturm
er ist nicht eingeknickt und er bleibt
bei seiner aussage auch bei mir im
interview war ihnen nicht klar wie
verdient dieses gelände
doch natürlich war das klauen und
deswegen führe ich diese debatte ja auch
seit ich auftrag für den neuen
bundesländern noch ein bisschen
intensiver als vorweg weil ich das
sozusagen als teil meines auftrages
empfinde ich habe auch noch mal intensiv
darüber nachgedacht was was kann man den
lernen also dem umstand wenn man viel
kritik aber auch viel zuspruch bekommt
wo man also ein aufreger produziert hat
wo es emotional wird ist aber immer noch
kein besseres wort als diktatur
sozialisiert eingefallen klar sagt
wanderwitz die rechten sind auch
anderenorts in europa auf dem vormarsch
aber er vergleiche eben nur innerhalb
deutschlands
und da habe ich halt die situation das
natürlich in baden württemberg mehr
menschen afd wählen
das ist in brandenburg aber eben nur in
absoluten zahlen war in baden
württemberg leben so viel mehr menschen
also müssen auf die prozentualen zahlen
gucken und da haben wir halt eine
dramatische ost-west-unterschied und der
besorgt mich und deswegen rede ich den
nicht schön oder weg sondern rede halten
auch wenn es weh tut wann der wird zeit
recht die debatte muss geführt werden
aber ich glaube ja es gibt noch ganz
viele andere gründe warum menschen im
osten anders wählen oder nicht wählen
das hat auch mit uns mit den medien zu
tun
[Musik]
ist euch bestimmt auch schon mal
aufgefallen wenn so etwas passiert wie
der anschlag in halle dann heißt es
immer ganz schnell
der osten wieder aber wenn so etwas
passiert wie in hanau dann fragt
interessanterweise niemand was läuft
denn da im westen falsch geht schon mal
damit los dass es ganz oft heißt der
osten ich meine es irgendwie elf
westdeutschen bundesländer und den osten
ich meine was soll das denn sein der
osten so dazu rufe mal im westen an bei
mandy tröger sie ist medienforscherin in
münchen
und aus deutscher also quasi doppelt
qualifiziert für den job hallo hier zu
sein
dann legen wir mal direkt los was sagen
sie denn woran liegt das denn dass
ostdeutschland immer noch so ein
bisschen wie fernes fernes ausland
beschrieben wird in den medien ja es
gibt immer wieder studien die zeigen
dass also auf quasi höherer ebene aus
chefredakteuren usw es vor allem
westdeutsche sind in ganz deutschland
und ostdeutsche das unterrepräsentiert
sind und das hat eben auch konsequenzen
in der berichterstattung das merkt man
an zum beispiel an den landtagswahlen
wenn es dann heißt der osten hat gewählt
wenn es einen gäbe in rheinland pfalz
wurde man nie sagen westdeutschland oder
die bundesrepublik hat gewählt ja das
ist halt ganz typisch für
berichterstattung und man sieht dass in
der bildung man sieht es auch in der
sprache
ja ja das macht sich ja auch in der
bildsprache bemerkbar wenn es irgendwie
um den osten geht was zeigen wir da oft
noch im trabi oder ein plattenbau und
das ist natürlich toll dass 90er jahre
klischee apropos ich las neulich auch
das im osten die überregionalen
westdeutschen zeitung wie spiegel und
zeit und so weiter dass sie da kaum abos
verkaufen richtig genommen und es wird
als negativ ihr also wird quasi gegen
ostdeutsche gewandt und gesagt warum
lest ihr keine zeitung
es heißt ja nicht dass sie keine zeitung
lesen sie lesen nur keine überregionalen
zeitungen die vor allem aus
westdeutschland kommen die arbeit quasi
die vielfalt diesen ostdeutschland gibt
gar nicht abbilden so und sie sagen
jetzt dass leute die sich nicht wieder
finde in der berichterstattung dass die
daneben ard wählen könnten ist es
wirklich so einfach
ja also wir gucken gerne auf die afg und
ihn auch
auf den osten und sagen ihr ja und sehen
aber gar nicht dass wir ja quasi erst
mal überhaupt die plattform dafür bieten
also die ard hat nur eine chance weil
verschiedene narrativer einfach aus dem
deutschen diskus rausfallen
die fdp setzt genau dort an wie sie
argumentiert wie die wahlplakate
funktionieren also es gibt einen grund
warum die immer wieder auf 89 90 zurück
sich zurück beziehen und sagen wir
vollenden die wende
das kann so nur funktionieren weil es
halt eine lücke gibt die nicht nur
schuld der medien ist die medien sind
nicht schuld aber die medien sind ein
ausdruck wenn das größeren
sozialpolitischen problems interessanter
gedanke das nehmen wir mit vielen dank
für das gespräch
hier ist nach münchen danke ja da gibt
es also offensichtlich in vielen
westdeutschen medien immer noch einen
großen blinden fleck in der ostdeutschen
berichterstattung und genau diesen
umstand macht sich die afg anscheinend
zunutze wenn ihr mehr wissen wollt über
diese massenmediale problemzone ost dann
habe ich euch die gleichnamige studie
hier unten nochmal abgelegt
[Musik]
vor kurzem hat der ostdeutsche
schriftsteller ingo schulze den dresdner
kunst preis bekommen und dazu hat er
dann eine wie ich finde spektakuläre
dankesrede gehalten da hat man so
richtig ausgeholt hier sind ausschnitt
und trotzdem bleibt die ungleichheit
zwischen ost und west skandalös heute
gibt es kein land in europa in dem einer
bevölkerung so wenig an grund und boden
an immobilien und an betrieben gehört
wie den ostdeutschen im osten
deutschlands keine bevölkerung die dort
wo sie lebt so wenige führungsposten
innehat wie die ostdeutschen sei es in
den betrieben in den medien den
verwaltungen den banken bei militär und
der polizei oder an den gerichten und
universitäten
es stimmt alles erbt die zahlen
tausendmal gehört ich selber hab schon
so oft drüber berichtet von 133
abteilungsleitern aller
bundesministerien sind nur vier aus dem
osten
im kanzleramt gibt es keinen einzigen
ostdeutschen top beamten in der obersten
verwaltungsebene ja und seit franziska
giffey als abgang gibt es auch keine
einzige ministerin kein einzigen
minister mehr mit ost biografie im
bundeskabinett der sagt jetzt die
regierung okay wir verlegen einfach ein
paar mehr bundes behörden in den osten
gut haben sie gemacht wie zum beispiel
das umweltbundesamt nach dessau sieben
sind es inzwischen schon von fast 70 und
was lese ich dann alle bundesbehörden im
osten werden von westdeutschen geleitet
das ist doch mist so war es nicht
gemeint aber ich hätte auch eine idee
habe ich den ostbeauftragten marco
wanderwitz auch gleich mal präsentiert
würde es nicht mehr helfen wenn wir in
der nächsten bundesregierung drei
minister aus dem osten hätten weil die
dann nämlich die ostdeutsche perspektive
qua geburt einfach mal mit an den
kabinettstisch bringt selbstverständlich
wird ist ministerinnen und minister aus
dem neuen ländern geben müssen ist
jedoch koalition er gut beraten das
abzubilden ob er selbst gerne minister
werden würde das konnte ich leider aus
marco wanderwitz in diesem interview
nicht rauskriegen aber sein chef armin
laschet der weiß offensichtlich dass er
an den ostdeutschen nicht mehr
vorbeikommt ich finde dieses kabinett
dass ich dann zu bilden die absicht habe
sollte paritätisch besetzt sein
mit männern und frauen und es muss
natürlich auch
ost und west vertreten sein und nicht
nur nordrhein westfalen die grüne
kanzlerkandidatin frau berbalk habe ich
das neulich auch mal gefragt auf einer
pressekonferenz hier schaut mal rein
frau hübscher hat die nächste frage
bitte ja hallo frau wenn sie die chance
hätten im kabinett zu bilden inwiefern
bilden sie aus deutsche minister
beteiligung und würden sie sich da
selbst mit quote verordnen
naja und dann kommt da halt so eine
politikerinnen antwort das ist überhaupt
nicht meine sache
bevor eine wahl gelaufen ist bevor
wählerinnen und wähler entschieden haben
über kosten zu sprechen sondern das
findet dann statt wenn in unserer
schönen demokratie wählerinnen und
wähler gesagt hat wer überhaupt
verhandlungen miteinander führen soll
fassen wir unsere drei punkte noch
einmal zusammen wir haben erstens
mindestens zwei kanzlerkandidaten aus
dem westen die im osten noch nicht so
richtig zünden wir haben zweitens eine
westlich geprägte medienlandschaft in
der sich ostdeutsche immer noch nicht so
richtig wiederfinden und drittens
ostdeutsche bleiben strukturell immer
noch benachteiligt also beteiligung
beteiligung beteiligung das ist der
schlüssel und zurück zu unserer
ausgangsfrage über die hälfte der
ostdeutschen weiß noch gar nicht wen sie
wählen soll im september kann also gut
sein dass diese wahl wieder im osten
entschieden wird und ihr wisst ja
zumindest verlieren kann man sie hier
so und wenn euch dieses video gefallen
hat dann gerne licon abonnieren
weiterempfehlen und wenn ihr jetzt zeit
habt schaut einfach weiter tolle inside
politics videos von meinen kollegen
haben wir hier verlinkt ich sage danke
und tschüss
und wo sind jetzt endlich die
knusperflocken